[Music]
could you hurt the Queen's Diamond
Jubilee you must've been excited about
that well not really because it sounds
like a not a real thing yeah a Diamond
Jubilee like what is that yeah it's a
Diamond Jubilee well karate chop it on
the neck for years you'll put down the
Queen and then the minute it's one of
her birthdays everyone loves me Queen
Mum again isn't it hypocritical isn't it
I think so I say it's time for a bloody
revolution yo really some people are
into it now you've got three people
so what only takes one to chop off
someone's it I'll have no part of it
yeah all right well so you're not throg
at the idea of the Jubilee well I still
write it's just like a reason people
need to have things to celebrate
otherwise we realize that we are
oppressed and are unable to express
ourselves freely because we're at the
behest of all these corporate entities
so yeah have a party to distract us from
the fact that would be in tyrannize why
not yeah well there's no better time for
us to take a commercial break